the new face of ukip
the party partly responsible for brexit
now resorting to online extremists to
get attention
i'm not going to be apologizing for my
crimes against political correctness i
hate political correctness
in footage obtained by sky news carl
benjamin the party's candidate for the
south west provides his own commentary
over an anti-discrimination video
in it he calls a disabled person a
[ __ ] and uses a number of racist slurs
he claims the remarks are jokes but
should freedom of speech
excuse political candidates using
language like this
it is not acceptable to call me a [ __ ]
you know what fair enough you can't
change that you're a [ __ ] and it's not
very nice for me to call your [ __ ]
i won't do it or call yourself or your
friends [ __ ]
whoa whoa whoa whoa what are you what
are you talking about
what are you talking about [ __ ] let's
discuss some of those comments that
you've made in the past and we
you and i i'm not really interested in
discussing any of these comments because
you see
i've had something like 400 million
views on my youtube channels in total
um i've got a huge audience that if
people want to go see them they can go
watch them on my channel and see the
context of them for themselves
in another section of the video mr
benjamin uses racial slurs
so off [ __ ] it's okay for me to call
you this
because racism is power plus prejudice
there are other sections of this video
which we can't show you because they are
too offensive
personally i find racism racist jokes
funny
this isn't the first time mr benjamin
has faced questions about his choice of
words
i previously challenged him over
comments he made about rape
there are people who are deeply offended
by some of the things that you've said
well i tell you what they can go and
have a cry and when they've collected
themselves and they're ready to talk
like an adult about the issues
and not bring up things that they think
might be offensive and spread them
around the country to people who might
be offended by them
then we can have a sensible conversation
about the issues you have a video where
you call chinese people chinks
and by all accounts because words have
meaning
and you don't know what the meaning of
that word was you don't know what
the context was what the narrative of it
is that's the point it's broadly
accepted as a racist term
yeah i know that's why i used it after
challenging mr benjamin on his comments
i asked him about the substance of his
campaign
okay so give me your top five policy
offers what's your what's your top five
on the doorstep well actual policies i
mean what can an mep even propose
so why has ukip the party which won the
brexit referendum
turned to social media agitators like mr
benjamin who caught the far right
they don't care about being called far
right they don't care about engaging
with far-right activists and approaching
and trying to get far-right voters
any normal party that was mainstream and
acceptable would have got rid of carl
benjamin already and would after this
but this ukip will not so what does the
party's choice of candidate
mean for brexit ukip's main cause and
the pledge it's been making to voters on
the doorstep
the rhetoric that they've used and the
characters that they employ to
to send that message are actually
themselves undermining
the the brexit the leave cause because
they are
giving the remain side if you like all
the ammunition they need
to say well hang on all the leave camp
are hard-line
right-wingers bigots were aren't
prepared to
engage in proper political debate
politics in britain
is splintering new parties have formed
along new fault lines but old tactics
have returned too
will the decision to embrace them make
or break the new ukip
kate mccann sky news and we approach
ukip to comment on mr benjamin's online
video on our interview with him but
they declined to do so